facts yeah you loved me you loved me so
what's wrong you gotta show him why are
you posting pictures of him I don't even
care you're a liar I can have you like
tomorrow
[Music]
all right guys welcome back
it is episode 297. it is episode three
apps away from the three dub [__] and
you might be wondering
if you pay attention we only do odd
numbers we only do odd numbers out here
yeah the public only can see the odd
numbers so you're not going to see
episode 300 yeah and until you head on
over to patreon I don't usually plug it
into a little bit further in the episode
but it's the the time is nice
the time is nigh brawl always and you
have to jump in yeah um so head on over
to patreon.com in gigs pay your boys a
cheeky three pound a month run the piece
of sng and you can hear us talk about
the gossip that we'd like to talk about
the certain things that we don't like to
talk about for the public to hear like
backstage your boys like to cook some
stuff yeah turns out I've got a wet
stone at home do you
back I sharpen my own knives do you
facts do you
do you but you wouldn't know that about
us that's something you didn't know
about us
um unless you jump over on patreon
thanks and uh speaking of things that
you didn't know about us did you know
that sometimes because your boys are
booked and busy we like to have someone
supplement our meals for us you know we
said it yeah I'm sometimes I'm too
famous to step into waitrose okay yeah
yeah sometimes I just can't deal with
the pictures and the autographs exactly
I want stuff delivered to the yard but I
still want to cook it exactly I don't
want it's not a microwave job exactly I
want to feel like I'm chefing up like
I'm chefing up I want to feel important
I want to feel like a man yeah and the
only way to do that sometimes with
hellofresh facts all right we're not
gonna you know how we do it we say juicy
at the beginning of the episodes we go
straight into that IG question so we're
not gonna took too much time to talk
about hello fresh right now so we're
gonna pause that get on with the IG
question and we'll get into details
later let's go all right let's jump in I
had your question of the week was what's
a minor inconvenience that can ruin your
day mine oh bro I've got a million of
these I can't wait for you I've got a
slip I was gonna swear I've got a
slipping dipping million of these
what's a minor inconvenience that can
ruin your day sharting
wow not one of them that's not mine
off the car sharting bro I remember
I remember
hearing one time I don't know if it was
on a podcast or something else just
hearing about like this is so Grim to
start the episode yeah how
um
how complicated your your balloon knot
is okay and how complex an organism your
butthole is okay and that it can
actually like the nerves in it can
obviously sense the difference between
like solids liquids and gases
so you know if you so like a sensation
in your guts yeah is the same either way
okay whether you've got uh whether you
need to Duke yeah diarrhea or just pop
yeah your butt knows yeah but no one
knows why your son knows it just knows
okay so like if I need to fart I'm
confident that even though my stomach's
bubbling yeah once like once you once
Daddy just relaxes a little bit it's
just air coming out yeah that's all
knows that yeah so when we're starting
yeah
something between the blood brain
barrier yeah it's off yeah I hear you
and I'm not dealing with that and first
of all so that's not first of all this
is like ninth of all minor inconvenience
is a minor inconvenience that's ruined
your day yeah it's it's sometimes people
don't know that they're gonna leave a
couple specs when they're firing yeah
but but I'm I'm assuming if you've done
it and you know you've left something in
there
you'll find it out there and then yeah
you're gonna find out there and then but
so I'm saying that's not a minor
inconvenience don't get me wrong that's
the worst possible thing I can imagine
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah especially if
it's like a liquidy-esque type that's
not me being oh annoying Another One
Bites not again thank God I bought
spares who's bringing spares
I was literally gonna say that word for
Words
the day is chalks bro yeah I said let's
shouting all right what's the main
inconvenience that ruins your day
finding out your crush got into
relationship oh my God
there's not enough F's in this facts bro
there isn't that stomach turning yeah
finding out your ex got into a
relationship no yeah sorry you're crying
your crush your crush going to
relationship yes
X is bad as well not for me
A crush with Woods yeah that was a break
a crush will murk me yeah but sometimes
in the X like
when they're in a new relationship this
hasn't obviously hasn't happened to me
in flipping years but like
I sometimes think that like but you
don't love him though yeah you know what
I mean because the way you were arrested
yeah that was your true self whatever
you give to my man is a facade
it's a facade
facts yeah you loved me you loved it so
what's wrong you gotta show him why are
you posting pictures of him I don't even
care you're a liar I can have you like
tomorrow
what is this like I don't understand why
you're trying so hard these games
hilarious oh it's mad bro but you love
me
jokes ah when I'm actually in the mood
to do my chores and my mum shouts go do
the dishes
that's very very drunk when you're in a
space right and you know them days where
you wake up and you're in a good mood
you feel like oh let me just clean the
living room
and your mom's like I'll go do this and
go do that it's like I was gonna do it
anyway bro let me do let me clean let me
do whatever I need to do in my own time
this how I was gonna do it anyway thing
that's as well when I said before I've
got problems with author Authority yeah
I've got problems I could have a dish in
hand yeah
and then all my mum would have to say is
like oh good because I was going to tell
you to do that anyway
I'm dropping on the floor
nice man you tell me what to do oh I
can't handle stuff oh it's jarring ruins
your day
ruins your day ruins your day I remember
one oh
ah
obviously I used to work in hospitality
and this is when I was still living back
at my mum's I'd gone home probably for I
don't know I could have still been
living in London before I moved to money
um and I think my mum had friends you
know when you know what parents are like
when they got their people over like
their friends or whatever they they want
to go a little bit overboard especially
when it comes to that showing off yes
showing off is the word showing off is
the word and my mum my mum asked me to
get her some food she was chilling with
one of my friends all over I can't
remember who it was she asked me to get
her food my mum food from the kitchen so
I did I can't remember what dish was I
got some food and I went back to my room
because I was leaving them to it my mom
said
how can you give me a plate this cold it
was a hot food by the way how can you
give me a plate this cold don't you work
in the kitchen
I think I think you've told me that
before I wanted to scream James I would
front kick the plate
straight it was the first one yeah don't
you work in the kitchen don't work in a
kitchen my Jeep get your facts straight
are you my mother or not do you know me
or not 100 bro I was then you don't say
stuff like that because you've got
friends around bro I was living how can
you give me a playlist called don't you
work in a kitchen
that's so disrespectful I know you're
entitled or not
that's
suspect
s but couldn't believe it well that's
not that because this is why I sometimes
I do wish I was brought up with more of
an iron Rod because my tongue would run
yeah yeah where do you work
let's talk about that for a second
how about we don't know we're gonna
where do you work I wouldn't leave the
office yes James I want to leave the
other weeks I can't be spoken to like
that I was so angry so angry I bet
ah anyway
um damn I'm sorry bro nah bro it's tough
tough parents get so gassed when a
bridge
like nothing they do I remember my dad
oh I remember when I was a kid I think I
wanted to be a physio okay I think I
might say this before I want to be a
physio before I knew what physio
actually was yeah I wanted to be a
physio before you way before uni because
all I loved was football yeah that's my
gateway to football I want to be a
physio yeah because I didn't know what a
physio actually did turns out they just
rubbed man's leg didn't know that yeah
so I was like yeah physio because
the careers advisor whatever I just said
I want to be in sport yeah and they just
said physio yeah so on track to doing
that
my dad thought I worked as a physio
for years really once we've left uni
for like
I don't know three years after when I
was personal training
he was telling people he was telling
people he's a physiotherapist yeah he
didn't he didn't know anything care
ful so I'd uncles saying like how's the
physiotherapy going
therapist
jarring bro but I didn't care you just
said whatever came to his head and
bottom of his day oh man he's just
thinking it's it's round about yeah
I don't know Manny awesome going on it
was broke
all I know is it's broke
because he's asking me
or internships
oh God hilarious yeah I'll learn what
it's called when you when you start when
you start making bread yeah stop paying
me back and I'll learn the job
she calls me how's my CEO doing faster
[Applause]
some [__] some broke boy [__]
facts bro don't you work in the kitchen
from kitchen worker to CEO yeah it took
our time but they should be ashamed of
themselves
they don't love us properly do what I
mean what do you mean from don't you
work in a kitchen run your hot plate to
house my CEO
oh cause my money's up how are you my
mother or not
oh
God oh are you my mother or not bro bro
[Laughter]
it's hilarious my juice
well played anyway what's the minor
convenience that ruins your day waking
up and see no notifications on your
phone whatsoever oh wow this is Mr
unpopular yes sometimes I refresh my
[__] I'm thinking I'll close it after I
open it again because I think Saturn's
not going through I'll be I'll be
looking at my data my service everything
I'm on airplane mode what's going on
nothing 24 hours nothing yeah fine
because I slept wow yeah dropping an
item and dropping a second item while
bending over to pick up the first
log very blood literally starts boiling
yeah bubbling under your skin it's like
for God's sake yeah yeah and it's
annoying because you're in public you
can't kick off the way you want to dash
the basket and kick everything it looks
like cotton yeah you've got to compose
yourself you have to compose yourself
a fly that's bothering me that isn't
targeting anyone else starring yeah
because you stink yeah that's what
you're saying you're just telling me I
think Jerry do you know what one oh my
God you know what one annoys me bro tell
me you know when you've got like the
tiny tiny little fruit flies or gnats or
whatever yeah and on a hot day they're
just on your cheek and you just don't
know
I'm with Ellis you've never seen that no
you've never gone like this on a hot day
and then you look and there's just a
like a little black spot on there yeah
nothing bro literally never [__] both of
you on my life literally ended the outer
sign then
because if you want to embarrass me
that's never happened in my entirety
you've never had like a little satin on
your face not by doing this and seeing a
bug on my hand my bro never swear
mothers touch your face more then and
you can [__] off as well say the next
one shot then
foreign
wow people coming into the cubicle next
to me whilst I'm taking a [__]
100 yeah 100 because you you fear yeah
bro you can't relax
your five minute break is now turned to
15. yeah because you've got to be you
gotta be tactical with everything your
black [__] locks in that [__] yeah
yeah
locks in bro Bros
I went I did that to someone the other
day he didn't care though okay because
he I walked in to piss yeah in the gym I
remember and it's the same way
listen you man once I first said the
funniest bar to me and I've never forgot
it when we were in the airport in
Heathrow before we went to Austria this
guy went to take a piss and he'd come
out he said
he said there were man in the cubicle
breathing like they're in hospital beds
oh I couldn't breathe I got people like
10 minutes
next to me
yeah like he just ran from treadmill to
the top oh fight for his life he was
like
and he yanked the thing so you know when
he pulls the toilet roll oh okay and he
goes
rip wipe rip white just breathing the
whole time I was like oh oh Dave he has
he has no manners he knows I'm in here
yeah yeah he didn't care
mind your business I have to read it if
I'm gonna do it anyway I'm gonna do it
here yeah I'm keeping myself to myself
and I was doing this before you even got
here so leave me alone if you don't want
to smell any more dick yeah yeah I want
to see who caused this dip yeah bro 100
but yeah when I'm in there my toes leave
the floor yeah my bossy locks up
I have to wait for whoever's next door
in the next cubicle to Flushing flush
and check out dip and I have to wait a
few seconds to hear that yeah
I want to hit the head and the hand
dryer
[Applause]
I let go because now we're covered
because everything you hear through that
is speculation
speculation that not might have even
been in this room facts yeah wow I've
never felt so much so relaxed when that
hand dries on I'll let anything happen
quickly as well because I don't know
when they're next I'm going to be free
and they all hang out
oh jokes
all right back to it what's the main
inconvenience that ruins your day
when they address you by your name and
say can I ask you a question
yeah can I ask your questions the
dumbest question yeah yeah just say what
you want to say don't put me on a
pedestal there's this thing is as well
like also
there's only so many words in my life
that I'm gonna hear so you saying can I
ask you a question that's six words or
just wasting time yeah asking me the
question facts ask me the question
there's only so many words my ears will
ever hear open and you could denying me
from just Majesty you know what I mean
yeah I hear you completely I'm telling
you all these open-ended questions are
long
haunted yet being left on red facts yeah
especially from someone special special
yeah yeah that would ruin your day wow
dropping my keys at the door when I have
to [__] really bad
um
one time I know I hate to make it a
shitty conversation yeah
um but yeah one time I remember
rocking yeah I ran in the door yeah I
had to dip upstairs [__] and then
obviously once you finish it and you're
not thinking like you're just Bliss yeah
yeah and hop I remember I came up
because I was in my ensuite flushed
wiped flush washed my hands
skipped out of the bathroom and jumped
on my bed yeah for like one of these
like yeah ones on my phone like 45
minutes later I went down to get a drink
the door was swinging open with the keys
on the outside dangling
I forgot what kind of rush I was in no
wow wow 100 yes wow yes I bet when you
walk downstairs you thought that's an
intruder video I said
you would afford as an intruder in the
yard bro oh my God that's scary that's
scary damn yeah because that was my most
vulnerable five and like 45 minutes ago
was my most vulnerable so who's here bro
they would have stormed it literally
like the role play that you said to me
there's not a worse time for a man to
bust in there
and while you're broken what vulnerable
boxes to ankles vulnerable there's
nothing you can't fight him you can't
because he's seen it a mile away his
dead ones I know for fact it was me if
I'm if I'm in a situation where I'm
running to the toilet or like trying to
get my keys in I'm running to the toilet
boxes to the ankles and my Top's off oh
yeah because I'm
I'm sometimes the top is off sometimes
my stomach's so painful yeah when I'm
when I'm really bad and I've got like
poisonous sometimes oh God
when I got some kind of Point you're
gonna you have to get a poison out
sometimes you know when yes
um tie their top up and then touch yeah
I have to like I I if there's no
flannels nearby or hand towels that I
could like grind here yeah or like you
want to buy something because your
stomach is turning I need to do this so
sometimes I'll wrap my top up and it
ends up being like a little crop top
thing and I'm there just oh just rock it
you know do you know what I do you know
what toxic I use right so a lot of the
time yet again if that if there's if
there's poison in me though yeah yeah
usually nine times out of ten I'm
hunched over like yeah I'm just like oh
on my phone I'm literally headed hand
like this bracket especially one of them
ones where you've just woken up it's in
a Morning Light and you hung overnight
or whatever oh my God and there's
poisoning yeah yeah you're just like
this Bracken Bracken Bracken but the
Tactical the tactic I do instead of
Leaning forward I sit up yeah let the
whole thing flush out let us sit up and
let the whole thing flush out swear yeah
yeah it helps oh nothing helps me
through that but just just bear it
through it just breath work
wow it's nasty oh my God and sometimes I
I'm on my phone I can't focus yeah I
locked the phone to dash it I can't
because whatever's turtle is hurting at
the moment yeah
hilarious oh hilarious hilarious right
my speed through these last ones yeah
yeah what's the main inconvenience that
ruins your day and unnecessary I miss
you Bax damn
of course when my finger slips through
the toilet paper and I get [__] on my
fingers
I think that's happened to everyone it
has happened it has happened to
literature it's the worst that is an
inconvenience I scream when Amazon oh
you start looking at a tissue like it's
their fault yeah yeah yeah bro and you
ever damn this is a very very very
period episode yeah fecal based
conversation bro
you get doo-doo under that finger now
good luck getting out that smell will
stick with you bro it's like yeah it
just stays there
it's like turmeric that [__] stays
there for days
[__] spice that ain't coming off bro
yeah that doo-doo yeah that's spent oh
my God I have to get the nail brush and
go after it soap after soap after soap
it's not going anywhere that's hilarious
that is hilarious
while they're so specific so on point
well you can't get that [__] off you
can't
ah when your boyfriend keeps calling you
whilst they're you're at your sneaky
Link's house oh that will ruin you that
would really because that level of guilt
yeah nah damn when you switch your
electric toothbrush on and the
vibrations aren't vibrating yep yep yep
yep yeah so frustrating yeah or it dies
mid brush and you just have to manual it
the way through because they're not
built for men they're not it's not the
same dexterity they're not built for
that
that sauce
so it's jarring bro
anyway go on driving behind someone
that's doing the speed limit that's
showing on me every day my boyfriend's
son oh wow yeah my boyfriend's son
having a boner at the wrong time and
place yep every male has been there yep
everything I don't think women really
appreciate how bad it is facts
especially like
14 to 19 yes that era yes that's easy
it's literally not funny yeah it's not
funny it's not at fault yeah we just get
horny yeah facts dropping Loose Change
on the ground and picking it up in front
of people yeah that's oh especially when
you can't get your nail under there to
scoop it and you're just there for eight
you're just there like I'm letting it go
yeah I'm literally letting it go yeah
when you walk into a room to do
something but you forget what it was ah
every human being I do that almost every
day it drives me insane literally
especially if it's upstairs because I
leak from pound on the stairs run into
my room and I'm just like why am I here
what am I doing here
so just like plopping the pillows and
stuff
and then you wait until you get in the
car yeah yeah
I circulate the room was like whatever I
was looking for is gonna pop up because
I can't remember yeah
right anyways welcome to the show
welcome to the show guys welcome back
thank you for having us in your living
room bedrooms trains cars in your ears
in there man uh today I've already said
if I say it again please guys if you
want to dodge yourself into the cult
baby situation that we've got over here
sng Studios yeah head on over to
patreon.com
real quick head on over there and donate
a lovely three pound a month 10p a day
run the P to your boys and your daddy's
at SMG and you're in that's what it
takes that's literally all it takes
little sign up fee and you're in that's
it and then you have access to so much
access to everything that you could ever
want everything you could ever want over
there your daddies are there just
rolling stuff just puppeteering standard
there's things over there there's
brayers over there someone commented and
said I didn't know everyone in the
Discord was so sexy someone said that
the other day come on I didn't know
everyone in the Discord was so sexy come
on you can be part there was a girl that
said that there you go you could be part
of that bro so you can be you could be
joining in on that there's people
chirpsing lips in and grips in over
there and you're just over here on
YouTube doing what
not subscribing not so that's what
you're doing not subscribing which
brings me to my next point if you are on
YouTube start subscribing facts there's
a little red button there and some of
you just adamant bullish adamant not to
press it you don't want what's best for
us and that's what's best for us is the
one mil plaque and that literally is
after I'm gonna
this is how much it means today I won't
make any more noise about subscribers
after that facts I won't make I won't I
won't make any more noise about
subscribers once that gold thing's
sitting there you man won't hear me say
subscriber again unless I'm unless I'm
just licking your asses let's say thanks
for stuff I'm gonna ask you man to do
nothing so just get us there and daddy
shuts up that's it I'm over it yeah mate
not too long to go yeah boy and for yeah
everyone who's listening
um please follow the Channel please uh
give us a nice review five stars are
preferable but whatever you say please
say it with your chest let's go and uh
again REM is not in the studio today
he'll be back next week so until then
um no top five people were not happy
about that not being a top five I'm not
surprised I'm not surprised because I
have such a love hate I know you do and
they know that you have a lot of people
they know that I have a look but um yeah
when he gets back we'll jump into that
as well right guys it's happened it's
here we forget about it but apparently
it's turned up just like it does every
year it's Father's Day facts Father's
Day Has Arrived guys and what are we
gonna do we're gonna show our
appreciation and there is no better way
than showing said appreciation than
treating the Father Figure in your life
too
hello fresh come on hello fresh we've
done this before come on your boys are
chefing up the game with hello fresh and
this time treat him to their limited
edition Father's Day menu for just 3.99
per portion so as I said guys this is a
limited time offer so we're going from
the 10th of June to the 23rd of June so
you've still got time to jump in and
it's valid for new and existing hello
fresh customers okay we like to hear
what we'd like to hear new and existing
customers and if you're thinking oh bro
if I canceled my subscription flip in
six months ago 12 months ago 13 months
ago I was there two years ago and I
canceled I wish I never canceled
Brothers fine as long as you canceled 12
months ago yeah or more you're a new
customer there you go sign back up
you're a new customer you get the offer
okay there you go right so flakes treat
us tell us daddies what's on the menu
what's the Father's Day menu obviously
as we as you guys know we love to cook
we like to cook new things and sometimes
we need more things in our repertoire
obviously hella fresh us up with that
and the three dishes I've chosen this
week is the barbecue beef quesadillas
you can't really go wrong with barbecue
beef quesity it sounds good quesadilla
exactly and I'm sure all the fathers out
there are going to appreciate it as well
you can cook that in under 20 minutes
it's just it's just buff it's just buff
they also sent me um the ultimate
chicken tikka masala and the rice as
well a company with the naan bread it's
buff bro I've never made a chicken
secret from scratch so I'm looking
forward to making it no one has bro this
is why we need companies like this
because no one has and no one will
patenting us all up coming with all the
ingredients on the side as well man it
just looks easy to make and the pictures
look pictures look fantastic and the
last but not least the one I'm looking
forward to the most the hot and crispy
fried chicken burger Sriracha mayo
Sesame chips and a [__] slaw my G um I
don't even know what that is
sounds and looks amazing pickles it
smells yummy you know one thing I like
about the actual chips they actually
give you potatoes they've got to dice up
and cook oh yeah
they don't play games I remember the
first time yeah I opened a bag thinking
who likes soggy chips yeah no one open a
bag it's just a potato it's a raw I said
Do It show them you care and do exactly
slice me up yeah yeah so you've got to
slice it up man it's gonna be buff this
the hot chicken and the hot crispy
chicken burger I'm looking forward to
making that looking forward to making
that looks good right guys as you had
said these meals are rapid okay so we
all know we're busy we're busy bodies
out here booked and busy bucks just 20
minutes just 20 minutes you can cook a
healthy meal for you your family your
father whoever there yeah so guys what
you need to do is do not forget head
into the description yes use the link
and order your hellofresh box today okay
but literally today that's all you need
to do that's all you need all right gang
let's get back to the episode cool right
guys let's take a very very quick break
from the episode two let you know guys
that if you didn't
no already if you haven't heard already
is smooth sack summer standard turns out
it's smooth sacks almost standard okay
we don't do grinding we don't do chafing
we don't do Brillo brush Burns bro it's
smooth sack summer this time around okay
yeah
we up boy so when you're playing in the
Summer sun make sure you're escaped from
pubes to bum let's go let's go that's
right guys this summer keep your balls
cool while still looking hot with
manscaped standard leaders in below the
waist grooming are making sure we all
have a ball this summer by giving our
pants Partners everything they need to
stay fresh right guys dive head first
into smooth sack Summer by going to
manscape.com
and for 20 off and free shipping
worldwide use our exclusive code sng
Sierra November golf thank you very much
let's get back to the episode going
um so before we carry on it's awesome I
finished succession
I where are you up to Ellis I have not
finished it right I've got four episodes
left I'm on season four oh
um so you I can say everything that I've
seen there because I think I'm on
episode five on I believe I think I'm on
the episode after he's
obviously yeah yeah that's the episode
my favorite is right not exactly not
exactly because you said it's a season
three foreign
lots of stuff happened before yeah yeah
um last thing I've seen was the episode
after he passed away
um obviously they were all in his yard
um
his little sightings little sister tried
to get her stuff she dropped all the
stuff on the floor oh [__] buckled on
the floor yeah get off me get off me get
off me yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
last thing I've watched but you finished
it right I finished it
so did you see those 10 10 out of 10
episodes where they 10 out of 10. so
which ones were there because I said
that the last show I'm pretty sure it's
the last two I would say it's I don't
think it's the last two I don't think it
was the last one I thought it was I
think I think number 10 only came out
like a couple weeks yeah I think it's
like seven eight or six and seven or
something number eight yeah because this
is what I mean Ellis had a cool uh
yesterday okay number eight has to be on
there can you Google and see which one
which ones they are because I swear to
God when I was watching it because I
intentionally didn't check which ones
were the 10 out of 10. to see if I could
deep which ones they want yeah number
eight has to be one of them yeah oh my
God whatever I was I promise you'll sat
on the edge of my seat from the
beginning episode to the end of the
episode mad it was phenomenal mad it was
phenomenal say less episode 10 bangs as
well this is a finale is it from that it
is nine and ten is it really it's nine
and ten what is them episode oh wait no
it's not sorry
it's season oh no this is saying it's
season three episode nine and season two
episode ten nah bro season four they
have a ten hundred percent season four
let me see where's I'm deep it's on IMDb
right yeah and it says they're the best
it says they're the best uh episodes
rated
oh God Conor's wedding was a deep
episode
oh God yeah
I've seen that one episodes of
succession season three episode nine
yeah uh 9.8 9.1 so where's the perfect
tens thing because these are saying 9.8
nine points on hmm never mind well
Connor's wedding was definitely up there
for me
uh so yeah you guys have seen both
seeing Connor's wedding now yeah yeah
that's absolutely passed away now yeah
yeah episode three on the plane blah
blah yeah yeah so that was phenomenal
yeah in my opinion episode 8 was
probably the best episode I've seen
Sailors uh yeah so yeah the ending is
mad is any potential season five or nah
I hope for their sake they don't do a
season five okay because the way they've
left things is like it's all sewed up
okay and like it's one of them ones if
they do start a season five there's no
so basically the end of season four
there's no Loose Ends okay so if they do
start season five they're gonna have to
start some [__] again and it's just not
worth it okay okay but
fantastic Series so when did you finish
it up by the way yesterday afternoon
okay so I'm assuming you've not watched
anything else bar succession until I
watched two episodes last night of that
that Disney plus anime oh yeah that's
the love my watch list um yeah 10 Goku
uh diamakio
really good yeah I'm thoroughly
thoroughly I'm on episode five or six
thoroughly thoroughly thoroughly
enjoying it oh gang okay they love a
cliffhanger okay oh my God okay last
night I slammed my laptop closed just
out of frustration just that frustration
bro it's so juicy okay so I'm enjoying
it like plot wise
I haven't enjoyed an anime like this
since God knows when
okay it's talking purely plot wise okay
um
it's like I haven't enjoyed a plot as
good as this since
um promise Neverland okay I know that
was like two years season one of Promise
Neverland probably like two years ago
three years ago that came out
um
really good really really good so yeah I
would have definitely advised that
um but yeah succession was
it was it became part of me I bet it is
a part of me too is I was the days where
I just sit there and binge it from yeah
bro so yeah it's afternoon tonight where
I would like
fall asleep at night like close my
laptop and then open my laptop first
thing in the morning yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my God I was so in there bro I'll be
by the time we record the next episode
I'll be done yeah we can me too yeah by
the time you guys are finished you're
gonna watch an emotional breakdown from
all of them from Kendall yeah different
episodes yeah Kendall that doesn't
surprise me yeah he stays breaking down
Roman okay and shiv okay all separate
times okay they lose it at times bro
okay wow wow the end is wow okay okay
wow the end is good okay wow the
ending's good bro I think Greg remains
my yeah my favorite guy there's one bit
I'm gonna uh I'm gonna have to spoil it
for you man it doesn't relate to the
story whatsoever okay there's one bit I
have to give Greg his flowers he stands
up to Tom in one episode
he sounds I've just done this one time
because you know Tom just bullies it
yeah always Greg does something that
piss his Tom off and then Tom finds out
about it so he goes He Corners him he
takes him into like a bathroom or
whatever what's going on swear swear and
he's like loses it then starts like
pushing Greg around yeah everyone's like
typical typical yeah yeah Tom smacks him
in his face Greg smacks him back oh yeah
stands up smacks him back stares at him
yes yeah Tom would have been like yeah
yeah I didn't know you had this in you
Tom wanted to do something else but then
Greg step forward again Tom just said
I was like let's go come up I love Greg
I'm not sure I love him um wow what an
ending okay really really thoroughly
thoroughly enjoyed that show okay [__] I
loved it bro no I can't wait I can't
wait to like I said uh next time we're
recording Monday I'll be up today and we
can discuss all right
cool so you've got a story for us I have
got a story for you guys
um so this was sent to me on Instagram
and I'm just gonna read away okay cool
so this is not dilemma then I'm asking
for help they're not it's not am I the
[__] they're not enough it's just a
story it's just a story okay I like this
something it's just a story I've read it
I read it the other day and it's yeah
I'll let you decide and judge all right
say less
my neighbor has a wife or a girlfriend
I've seen them kiss hold hands all of
that
during the day when his wife is at work
I noticed another girl that was coming
over during the day didn't think
anything didn't think anything of it at
first I was minding my business
but their door is like right next to
mine and I see her every day coming over
stay for about an hour or so and leave
so I was like man let me do some
detective work of course
I started noticing when she was leaving
she always has her hood on always and
she scurried down the steps and go
straight to her car quick and then leave
he didn't walk with her nothing just
show up and then left the next day I go
outside of my car where I had parked in
a handicap yes I know I shouldn't have
forgive me but that's not what this is
about well I come downstairs there's a
cop by my car and Greg and he says to
the cop it's his car pointing at me
the cop asked if it's mine I say yes and
the cop writes me a ticket I give Greg
and Greg gives me the look and just
walks off while I'm standing there
getting a ticket issue to me like
seriously so I'm sitting there thinking
oh Gregory you have no idea what you've
just done oh no so wait so so just to
pause yeah
quick at this point all Greg's done is
just say this is not my car it's his
yes he didn't call no cops to say
someone's Parts in a handicap I I don't
know so read that again that's not
what's in the store he doesn't say to
anyone's called anything so the next day
I go outside where I parked in a
handicap yes I know I shouldn't have
forgive me but that's not what this
story is about well I come downstairs
and there's a cop by my car and Greg
um and he says to me and he says to the
cop
um it's his client points at me
okay so I think the cop is just asking
about yeah
and he says um it's his car so man said
Greg you don't know what you've done
don't know what you've done he's issued
a ticket say less sounds like he was
getting it regardless but hey all right
fair enough so I'm sitting here thinking
oh Gregory you have no idea what you've
just done
so I'm just waiting waiting until I see
Greg's wife again
I'm throwing this man under the bus like
a mechanic Oh my days I couldn't wait
so I had to get food that night and what
do you know her and I pull up at the
same time man life sure is sweet Greg
I say hey um you're Greg's wife right
she says yes why and I couldn't wait to
tell her why I applied
been planning this all day raw I said I
haven't met you yet by Matt Greg and his
sister earlier today she seemed sweet
she said his sister I said yeah she was
up there today she's been coming a lot
lately sibling love hey
she said Greg doesn't have a sister I
said oh man didn't know what else to say
so I just headed upstairs
enjoying my food while hearing Greg be
told to leave he's gone my stomach is
full and my car is in handicapped but
what's alive
might as partner again partner again and
that was it imagine
I need she'd have to tell me who who
told you this [__]
fax bro because like obviously this is
not we don't condone this kind of
behavior but bro code is broken yeah
yeah so you mean to tell me because you
parked illegally and I wasn't willing to
take the rap yeah and you got written up
a ticket
you're trying to hold me up now we're
just breaking marriages this is what we
do ruin a household this is what we're
doing because of a ticket
ah I know I said in the patreon episode
I'm just not Petty enough yeah um I
promise you're not paying enough of that
yeah because that's that's that's uh
unnecessarily calculated meticulous
attack
calculated meticulous attack is exactly
that's exactly what that is and it's
uncalled for over a ticket over a ticket
you know Big Mac I'm kicking down your
door fam you need to mind your business
yes 100 I promise you because in my head
at that moment I've got nothing to lose
Rago I've lost it all yeah I've got no
home yeah so if I get arrested tonight
at least I've got somewhere to sleep
facts sorry it's going off I've already
got a ticket I might as well get
arrested bro it's game over bro I'm
kicking down your door what do you mean
you told my wife about her yeah that I
had it all sussed out
that is just
ah nah man and you just upstairs eating
satisfying yourself satisfied still
parked in a handicap nah bro his car is
getting written off that same night Rags
it has to be it has to bro
that's very Peak
um yeah stay in your lane and don't ruin
people's lives long story short that's a
juicy story that is I said oh Greg you
have no idea what you've just done
I'm telling you we said before these
Americans bro I can tell it's America
100 bro chill out they don't mind their
business they literally they really
don't mind their business don't mind
them not in the slightest that's
frustrating it's frustrating it really
really obviously don't cheat and then
especially don't cheat in your own yard
plus every day yeah see that's
it's one of those ones where
he was
not uh Gregory was bound to get caught
100 he was bound to slip up and do
something because one you're probably
bringing her quote-unquote sister around
the yard exactly around the same time
every single day she's doing the same
routine parking down the road walking up
getting banged for an hour coming out
hold on and scurrying back to the car
she's doing the same also if you're not
hooded up when you come in why are you
gonna buy it on the way out like come on
bro like it's
if you want to Pat and sign up properly
just paying it well yeah yeah you
deserve to get caught in fact 100
deserve to get caught in your marital
home you have no respect zero yeah and
obviously it's in the marital bed yeah
obviously I'm not buying it in the
kitchen every day
we have to do we have to do our
traditional stuff sometime sometimes
um it's not all fun I need comfort too
but yeah um you deserve to get caught
and you deserve to get out because
you're silly you're silly but anyway
I've got an am I the [__] all right
tell us am I the [__] for telling my
niece to stay in the closet until she
gets her inheritance
my niece is 17 uh she's a female
obviously I'm 42 male recently confided
to me that she is a lesbian I supported
her let her know I'd be there Etc usual
Ally stuff however
she told me she's going to come out of
the hole to come out to the whole world
this week I let her know
she should absolutely wait for her
grandparents my parents to pass away my
father is incredibly wealthy and has
tens of millions of dollars in assets
that he'll be passing down once he's
gone
my father is a raging homophobe who has
he must flat out stated any gay
individual in our family would be
written out of the will and to make sure
the rest of us don't just split the
money with the gay relative they will
instead have the portion of the
inheritance put to the side put aside
for the family member and donated to
charitable causes instead
the money will be erased from The
Inheritance
since both my father and mother are
incredibly poor health stage 4 cancer
and debilitating dementia respectively I
told Manny she should stay in the closet
for a while longer if she comes out as a
lesbian I find out she will quite
literally lose her on seven million
dollars
she was a little sad but was also
appreciative that um since that is
obviously life-changing amount of money
and that will allow her to live a
luxurious life until she dies my wife
however said that I'm being an [__]
I'm telling her this poor girl to hide
who she is to appease these old bigots
that is true and I am asking her I am
asking her to appease the old bigots but
I feel like her quality of life will be
much better with seven million dollars
at a cost of one to two years in the
closet at at most
I have um I've seen my father as well
and I know who is getting what my niece
is definitely getting seven million
dollars and um as long as my father
doesn't rewrite or enter the will am I
the answer for telling my niece to stay
in the closet so she can be a
millionaire
that's a really really good and mighty
[__] yeah that's a really really good
one I enjoyed that Authority
um personal
I don't think you're an [__] at all
because especially if she appreciated
that yeah and she said she appreciates
the advice because one
how can I be an [__] if I don't stand
to gain anything from telling her yeah
to do this yeah I'm getting my money
yeah regard regardless of what you do
I'm getting my money so I'm purely
looking out for you facts and this whole
like coming out thing like don't get me
wrong I'm sure obviously never done it
yet
um but I'm sure coming out is
a very important like almost like a
coming-of-age situation yeah freeing
liberating powerful moment yeah but this
whole like she's hiding her identity to
appease bigots it's like I don't
necessarily believe in that because it's
like
Define hiding your identity
there's a million people in your life
that you're gonna meet every day that
have no idea that you're gay yeah and
you are not even gonna bother to mention
it yeah and it should be so intertwined
in your life in my opinion that you
don't shouldn't feel the need to tell
everyone yeah that you're gay what yeah
it doesn't it shouldn't make that much
of a difference yeah yeah so why is it
not part of normal conversation it's not
part of normal conversation and it
doesn't it's not
it's not part of your identity it's like
it is is like part of like obviously who
you are but it's not it's not what
defines you as what I'm trying to say
yeah it is part of your identity it's
not it's not what defines you so whether
you tell them or not doesn't affect how
you live your life yeah it doesn't
affect how you move yeah it doesn't
affect the things you do yeah so if he's
saying bro I wouldn't tell them you know
because if you do this guy's an [__]
and he's gonna take seven M's off of you
just take the seven M's and you're still
gonna be eating pom
yeah yeah don't let him find out
find out yeah
seven M's don't don't be stupid yeah
facts
all this emotion stuff
how about you tell Granddad sight and
you don't want to hear facts I was
talking about who's a bigger
we'll see what M's you get yeah facts
you're not even in the ball it's easy
for you to say you'll be grips on my own
I'm sorry for sure why did I go tell him
I'm gay and we'll see what comes out of
your mouth exactly you'll be saying
Daddy please Daddy don't do it daddy you
don't do it I need a new one I need it I
need that whip now I need a Birkin Oh my
days yeah yeah you've been looking at
yards I see you
broke
however I tell my Dad I'm good what are
you gonna say Dad pharaoh who do you
think you are factual because yeah like
I said he doesn't start to gain anything
from him he doesn't he literally dies
he's definitely definitely definitely
not an [__] I feel like he's doing
the best thing as an uncle yeah he's
really looking out for his knee
especially yeah especially if he's seen
the will he knows what she's getting
exactly and then in my opinion he would
be an [__] to not say anything in
fact a bigger [__] if he was just
yeah just to not say anything at all and
just be like yeah do you think knowing
what's gonna happen if she does yeah
that's that's [__] behavior that is
very much seven M's is literally a life
changing and you're gonna be you're
gonna do all right for the rest of your
life you don't need to work again for
the rest of your life so let's yeah that
that's stupid stupid Behavior wow
that's mad also I know it doesn't sound
anything to game
but he's probably a bit like if I deeply
deep it he's probably a bit nervous
thinking bruh if she does come out yeah
I'm not because I'm not trying to get
rid of the way myself okay so
if she comes out yeah and he writes
about the will yeah and doesn't chat to
her and all this kind of stuff the
Grandad the Grandad it's like I'm gonna
have to defend her Denise Denise yeah
and I don't want that kind of conflict
yeah
I don't want him right now nothing give
me half give me half at least yeah it's
not me but you know yeah she's a child
she's a child bro I'm a Defender but I
need M's yeah yeah I need it yeah I'm
your child yeah
I'm your child and I've mentally planned
them yeah yeah I've been window shopping
for years please I need it yeah and I
made promises I listen to your breathing
Bro you've got not long left you haven't
we're so close do the right we're so
close we're so close
talk to him she's got the match talk to
him please I'll be trying to coerce a
conversation yeah oh my days yeah I have
no idea this is I'm so happy that my
like my dad's obviously does all right
yeah but I don't think he's got M's for
me yeah I don't think he's got hands
with me so I'm grateful for that yeah
I'm so grateful for that I'm grateful
I'm I'm holding my own right now I'm
grateful bro cause I'm not because it's
always the random they've got M's are
are tyrants yeah yeah
tyrants in same thing in succession
Greg's Granddad yeah he had him running
around he had 250 M's for him
that yeah that's crazy I'll do what you
tell me to do but I need like I need
some I need to see something yeah yeah
you can't just say it to me yeah there's
250m's waiting yeah yeah because you
change your mind all the time all the
time so I need I need a contract saying
no matter what I'm getting this 250.
yeah but the ground I was never gonna
play that kind of game ever because he'd
be like yeah you're a blood sucker get
away facts he is the Granddad knows when
man said it's about 250 yeah M's I was
like that's awesome and it was what only
a three percent stake or something like
that yeah ridiculous wow that's about
250 where's style royco they make
billions yeah that's that's a money show
billions
billions oh my God I was gonna talk
about more about it
I promise damn yeah yeah right you've
got a thread for us to finish on yeah
yes sir right so this thread was a post
on Instagram and it was just all of the
comments but I wrote the comments down
on my phone all right gang so the thread
was comment like a hurt girl on her IG
story
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so I just
wrote that a few
she was a deer but she was afraid to
hunt oh my God
oh he was afraid to hop yeah yeah she
was a deer but he was afraid to hunt
shut your mouth bro
she was a deer and he was a Honda Civic
he here and drove off
Oh my days I can buy my own flowers
she was an open book but he was a
literate she thought that was so jarring
man it was an open book where he was a
literate why is it among females it's
never her fault it is never she's never
just buzzed do I mean or annoying or
whatever oh yeah yeah
why he
is but homeboy couldn't read
get out of my face man glitchy cow my
face bro
oh it does no one no and I know it's
like no fat Brethren yeah of the girl
I've just played yeah could ever come to
me and tell me she's an open book but
you're just illiterate because obviously
it's the fat version yeah yeah yeah fat
it's not her facts and sometimes it is
her and that's just obviously like shut
up what were we lying about yeah what
are we actually lying about here you
can't lie to me yeah I know you
all right if you wanted to he would
standard that is kind of sometimes it's
true sometimes it's also sharp yeah
working up because we didn't this is my
favorite
[Music]
[Laughter]
because we did it yeah
literally shut up wow that's funny this
one is my favorite one realize Realize
Real Life
realize realize real life oh my God all
right Nicki Minaj sharp man oh that's
Joe Oh my days
I don't regret the love I gave because
you probably needed it
right this is this is brutal she was a
fairy but he clipped her wings yeah
you lost the Moon while staring at the
stars
[Music]
man was stargazing oh facts bro them
stars were bright bright and the moon
don't do nothing it just stays it stays
there it's been there yeah get active
these man's a dart in across this guy
do something for me bro these are the
sparkling bags my shoes yeah I'm making
wishes up there do something
oh God that's funny you're just too
reliable Oh my days I got a few more
yeah
um comment like a hurt girl on her IG
story my son is my king
hurt people hurt people yeah sharp I
wish you the best but you already had
that
oh
wow this is so triggering
find a guy that ruins your lipstick not
your mascara yeah I had I've actually
seen that one before
I didn't turn the page I closed the book
look at me
done
oh my God I didn't change the page I
caused the book she had enough yeah yeah
literally had enough oh wow that's funny
that was it wrapped up that's hilarious
bro I can't stand indirect oh bro
indirect foolishness yeah say some to me
do you know
um I'm contemplating like unfollowing
shade bro you know I think about that
quite a bit swear not just shea butter
but like all of them
not just whatever there's another one
um end tv
yeah I because I like them for memes and
[__] and tweets and threads they do good
ones but when I'm seeing like when's
Steph Gonna Leave burner boy alone
bro I can't stand to look at it all the
time oh the ones I hate is when they
post they post a picture or still of
something for example UFO sighting blah
blah blah they they describe everything
that happened I'll click the link in our
bio show me the video facts show me the
video I'm not going to your page yeah
yeah show me a video they click the link
in the bio is so fast you have to search
sometimes they're even adding it on a
different page yeah it's like for the
full details go to this page what I'm
talking about yeah it's jarring bro but
yeah I can't take the celebrity gossip
and I can't stand to see what I hate is
when Shea bar will post something about
you yeah and then you as the celebrity
in the crosshairs yeah head to Twitter
to defend yourself yeah and then they
posted
sorry bro you can't win this game that
happened with um uh was it craps or was
it currently yeah it was uh it was crap
crap yeah but he's defending his girl or
his new girl yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
they just reposted
ammo bro it's embarrassing oh it's so
embarrassing just stops yeah yeah yeah
that's long that's long that's long
because they did that because this one
run about with the the Steph London
thing yes
she tweeted satin the other day yeah
miscellaneous miscellaneous tweet yeah
and then they took it and was like looks
like she's still upset about burner's
new thing yeah and then she had to take
to it again I wasn't even this is who I
chat about but I'm like stop doing it
yeah why are you fueling you're so lame
just get on with your life
yeah facts but it must it must get Jared
but then again of course it gets jarring
I feel like if you're a celebrity at
that status or at that at that Pinnacle
of that status or whatever you're gonna
get
indirects every day every day so just
crack on literally crack on bro and if
that's the thing as well they're like
little it's like when your mom when
you're getting bullied at school yeah
and your mum's like just pay them no
attention they'll get bored yeah that's
exactly what shade bird is like yeah
yeah they add the people consistently
that they know are going to get
triggered yeah and head straight to
Twitter they're refreshing your feet as
soon as you reply they're like gang yeah
if they do it to you and you just air it
yeah they'll allow you this is when you
you might see me on a keyboard sorry
that my face is in there
and I'm like
jokes run up but yeah man anyway guys
we're gonna leave it there we are man
thank you so much for being with us
today this has been a penguin yes sir um
enjoy the summer it's smooth sack summer
City boys are rap fact let's get after
it and uh as always love love love gang
gang
[Music]
foreign